what's important is that scientists find
putting pantyhose on your head makes
your mask safer
after testing seven ways to make masks
seal better around the face researchers
found that a pair of
hose hoses urea
hosiery does the trick best yeah
they're screw
look at this image it is obvious they
are screwing with us
they are going to be people who are
going to be wearing panties on their
face
there's people who are going to do this
they're doing a double masking thing
yeah they're doing a bit yeah it
obviously works it it tightens the pole
but so does scotch tape i mean what's
the point
what are they trying to
trying to sell pantyhose they're
literally trying to embarrass you i
think that's what it is they want people
to be humiliated this really does look
like they're trying to see if they can
get people to do it like there was some
some scientist and he was like hey but
if we tell people to put panties in
their face they'll do it they'll do it
like they're stoned as they're like
sitting in the lab and it's like dude
i'm gonna i'm gonna write it up and he's
typing no way they're not gonna fall for
it dude tell him you gotta like pull it
extra tight well pull it tight and
they're laughing and they submit it and
vice is like oh wow oh and they publish
it these guys are just like high-fiving
each other yeah they chest bump and
they're like we did it why is vice
making this an article is the bigger
question why do they think it's
newsworthy to to propagate this kind of
information to their audience because
they want to save lives luke
modus operandi
mummy look at this one it's called mummy
oh my gosh so they have a bunch of
different styles of putting a mask on
and they have tying the bands no hack
tape look at that
pantyhose white and pantyhose black dude
this is such colored pantyhose do better
look at look at that look at the mummy
one what what what does that mean all
right dude mommy the person who made
that graphic does not do any of those
things and they don't know anyone else
who does either what if you saw a mummy
guy at the airport if you saw somebody
like that with their face bandaged like
a mummy's face that'd be so hilarious we
have space helmets that's true yeah you
want
to take one of those with music so
here's the funniest thing though so we i
bought these big plastic helmets that
they were marketing at the start of the
pandemic like why wear a mask when you
can wear this
and you can't hear someone when they're
talking a lot of people point out like
what if you sneeze because it's like a
space helmet gross and here's the best
part you can't wear them on planes
anyway
yeah they're not i still want you
wearing a mask because yeah that's what
the rules say and they follow the rules
to the tee but it is a mask the rules
are very important
it does not work as a mask it has to be
a cloth mask so you have if you want to
wear the space helmet you can literally
be wearing a space helmet in a hazmat
suit and you have to wear a mask
underneath and then if i reach in to
pull it down to take a sip what if you
put the cloth mask like over the plastic
of this face
that might work that's an interesting
point because you'd be like i'm wearing
the mask well it's like apparently this
plastic that like doesn't really do
anything so dude it's about obedience
exactly there was there was a guy who
wore pantyho he wore panties on his face
which which is a cloth mask and they
kicked him off this is great well they
didn't see this article yet he's the one
who wrote it and that not pantyhose
this is oh
women's underwear i want to make a crude
oil
sheamus get ready cover your ears
i'm going to make a crude i'm going to
make a cream and there's a reference
you know make sure your ears are saying
say ian there's a lady present as i said
did i call you ian
he's the one i'm used to saying things
that make me uncomfortable
oh yeah ian i love you you know they
should yeah they're going to prepare the
people you ready they're going to
prepare this is preparation for the u.s
diplomats that are going to be going
into china who are going to have to be
tested in a very specific way that i've
been warning about for many specific
years which the chinese government is
bringing back specifically for the
olympics with their butt swab covet test
it's not even swabbing it's butt
insertion because it uh it's
it goes out it's literally it's just a
medical procedure that's nice oh so they
don't swipe they just go in they go in
they don't swipe they get how is that
normal is that better than the nose i
don't get it
people are doing it that's what's
happening in china yeah because they
can't use their hands to resist they
just hold them down the u.s state
department had to send an official
notice to china saying stop doing this
to our diplomats
yes
i wonder if now they're bringing it back
for the olympics i wonder if fauci and
bill gates are just like
taking big bong rips in in the back room
laughing and and bill's like you should
tell him to put pantyhose on next and in
fact he's like hey well and then we'll
tell them to wear two pantyhose dudes
they're literally beavis and butthead
right
hey bill i like that
hey bill
that would [ __ ] that would be cool
yeah
what make them wear uh
what's next that's the question what
what are they going to make you do next
here's the thing you use it's like gotta
start
out right gloves because infections are
going right they never did gloves i'm
surprised i hope i'm right
there they're gonna be i don't know i
think this i well i think because cases
are going down and they're desperate to
search for other stories the covet stuff
might start to fizzle out and they're
just gonna try to replace it with a new
story at the cove i mean the actual
virus is mutating and now we've got
delta strain or we kind of
where you've been we've got them all now
which is less deadly so i think that the
whole pandemic thing is seems to be
quieting down and it just feels like it
the last couple weeks well the cases are
going down dramatically uh in canada in
the united states and there's trends
that uh you know people countries like
south africa are following and we're
following those trends very closely
and that leaves a lot of room for
optimism and there's also going to be a
lot of people wanting some significant
um
how do you say this um accountability
revenge yeah
but i didn't want to go there
but there's going to be a lot of people
who are going to want to hold the
government officials that lock them up
accountable for
their uh crimes against them yeah yeah
no i mean people are going to be very
upset people are going to be very upset
about it but that's why the media is
going to do everything they can to just
try to talk about something else of
course they're not going to go like well
you know cases are down things are okay
you can go back to normal life they're
literally just going to stop talking
well they're going to need to shock the
general public with something dramatic
to get us away from paying attention to
the reality of the larger circumstances
that are going to be unfolding within
the next few weeks you think they'll uh
do a false flag in ukraine i've been uh
well this is what the u.s state
department is saying that russia is
going to do
um very very uh
there was a press conference by the
state department they were questioned by
a journalist specifically asked about
this because the state department came
and said that they were going to do a
false flag and adjourn the journalists
was like this is like alex jones stuff
that you're talking about and the state
department couldn't answer the question
of any kind of legitimate evidence
presented accusing russia are they going
to do a false false flag where they have
an american do some crime and they're
like that was a russian dressed us in
america oh my goodness
so many levels possibly there's many
different possibilities here but wars
are started under many times
historically through false flag
operations
historically you know because because
you can't just
preemptively attack someone um and just
say we we just needed to do so you need
an excuse for the general public to go
along with it you need an excuse to
build up the morale of this of the
soldiers uh to get them to go out there
and to commit some of the most heinous
atrocities against other human beings
you need a motivation factor um so
there's a big possibility of this what's
that cass's belly
it's a cause for an actor situation
provoking or justifying war yeah so
there's like there's got to be something
for it
like your great great grandfather owned
that land and now you have a right to it
could be that typically no it could be
it's got to be a grievance yeah so it's
like it's really funny too because often
in justifying a war it's to like
convince other people that you know
you're on the right side or whatever so
they side with you otherwise it would
just be like i'm gonna win the war and
declare it so i'll you know whatever
that's how it used to be it's like we
know we're gonna win so we go to war now
with the international stage it's like
okay we'll go to war but we need to make
sure everyone thinks we are the good
guys that's why you first needed
information war before you actually have
a hot war you need the build up you need
the the the pr you need all
you need to convince people because when
it comes to war when it comes to killing
another fellow human being you really
have to sell this idea uh as a life and
death situation and what better way than
to false flag an event to start this
because no one wants war
the bankers the the corporate heads the
billionaires they want wars and they
will stop nothing at getting it if
country leaders got together like biden
putin she all these leaders that they
could do something that would be more
powerful than global banking
um i i don't know about that um i i
think you know i was i was thinking you
were going to say they were all going to
be dosed by dmt yeah that was first
and then maybe there's a potential for
understanding this that's i thought i
thought you were going there for sure uh
but that's a very hypothetical question
that i don't have the answers to
i wish i did i wonder where the power
lies i usually think it lies in the
military but like you're saying
information and economics
someone super chatted gulf of honking
the gulf of tonkin is an excellent
example for anybody who doesn't believe
in false flags they tell you're crazy
and alex jones be like we're talking
about gulf of tonkin it's on wikipedia
yeah like the america americans claimed
they got attacked
germany's invasion of poland there was
an attack on a radio station that was
questioned as there was prisoners that
were dressed up in german uniforms and
polish uniforms there was allegedly a
skirmish where poland attacked germany
first
operations northwoods yeah there's
there's so many instances even you know
the sinking of the there's questions
about the lusitania the spanish-american
war uh there's there's so many of these
incidences that of course it's it's it's
more common than uncommon and we should
always be wary of them especially with
such a tense situation unfolding right
now between the united states and russia
with the military-industrial complex and
the corporate media pushing everything
towards the direction that's going to
mean some kind of war in ukraine which
is going to be they need estrous they
need it i want to i want to make two
very important points absolutely super
chats the the the democratic
establishment is in such dire straits
they need a conflict war usually does
really well for leaders i don't know if
it'll work this time around because we
got the internet but the other thing you
need to understand is
joe biden should already be campaigning
and fundraising donald trump already is
now not full scale
but the fact that there's not even any
kind of hints of of re-election work on
joe biden's part leads me to believe
there's there's we're starting to see
the beginning of evidence he's not going
to be running for 2024. if it's true
he's saying he's gonna right but come on
look at the guy if it's true that biden
is not running we would probably know
within the next four months because the
democrats need to get people fundraising
for primary season and normally with an
incumbent president they'd be gearing up
saying support us
but joe biden's not doing it yet
we'll see just so you know though which
we should know very very soon biden's
inviting russia to to invade ukraine
with his statements and comments on that
situation
which which is only getting more tense
with the united states shipping and more
weapons sending in more troops it's it's
crazy thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you